one of the most familiar images of
Yosemite National Park is Half Dome the
parks tallest Granite Peak at nearly
5,000 feet it's popular with hikers and
while it is a 10-hour Trek and not for
the meek a climb here requires no
special expertise and while thousands
may have made the trek with nothing but
some sore leg muscles to show for it
clear warnings are posted that a climb
here could be deadly
because Half Dome is a gigantic natural
lightning rod on July 27 1985 five men
set out to climb Half Dome Adrian
Esteban was one of the hikers it was
predominantly a blue sky with just one
little cloud way off in the background
we're hiking along and we got about the
halfway point we notice the cloud is
getting closer into the valley and now
it's getting darker and darker but he
says the excitement of the storm
actually drove them to try to finish
their goal a single thunderstorm can
contain more energy than ten atomic
bombs and lightning strikes on average
killed more than 40 people each year in
the United States between 2000 and 2009
by 6 p.m. despite the storm Adrian
Esteban and his friends reached the
summit their showdown with Yosemite
seems to have gone their way
but the storm was just beginning to slam
into half dome escape is impossible
desperate they seek shelter in Iraq
enclosure but it's too late I felt my
skin tingling tingling sensation
I felt like my hair was scanning on ant
and that's when the lightning bolt hit
the summit took a direct hit millions of
volts of electricity arc over the wet
stone surface into the rock enclosure
the lightning strike kills two of
Adrienne's friends two others suffer
massive internal injuries along with
third-degree burns and they take years
to heal Adrien was in motion when the
lightning struck because little of his
body was in contact with the rock he did
not ground the lightnings electrical
charge and he escaped with minor
injuries and I just want to impress on
people that the dangers of nature how
strong how unpredictable it can be a
hike on Half Dome can be an exhilarating
experience for those who decide to make
the trip but it is important to respect
nature and like the caution signs warned
don't climb this granite peak if a
thunderstorm is anywhere in the horizon